If I wanted to type x is less than or equal to 3, I would type in on my keyboard
x, a backslash symbol, the letters l, e, and then a space. Right after you hit
the space, the backslash and the le will transform into a less than or equal to
sign and that's also what this letter stand for, less than or equal to. If you
don't type in a space after these characters, then nothing will happen. Once you
have entered a space you can continue typing. I would just set 3 to get x is
less than or equal to 3. I have greater than or equal to symbol works in a
similar way. You would type backslash then ge, and the space. You're going to
have a chance to practice that here and here, just by typing in what I have
written here. And then as a challenge to you, you'll be able to try these 2
inequalities. Notice that they contain an infinity symbol. For the infinity
symbol, you simply need to type in a backslash and then the letters inf and a
space. The space again will transofrm these characters into your infinity
symbol. For this infinity, it's negative. So, I put a negative sign in front
first. This is just the minus sign or the dash on your keyboard. Try playing
around with your keyboard and see if you can get these same math expressions
using MathQuill. It's pretty cool.